that 10 pretend game back in the bubble
still gives me nightmares man
that was not fun
but then luca has put
zubots in the blender more than once
when you think about past matchups
with a score inside and left alone for
way too long luca finally decides to
take the three and nails it
all right
shoot with
two got hung up three team fouls on the
clippers in the first quarter
luca gave it up got it right back into
the shot clock bye bye to zumax and the
giant killer
got played off the floor in these switch
situations
and they couldn't play him a whole lot
actually
to those guys that are in the lineup
right now i think all of it is set up by
this guy right here
[Music]
this guy right here is doing some damage
he is putting the hurt on the clippers
early in the first quarter of the game
tonight with three made threes
which has been his immo and first
quarters actually
and another big one tonight
eight straight game where he's just been
absolutely outstanding in the first
quarter and here he is on the move
catching it with momentum to the cup to
score again
here is luca once again against zebots
just absolutely torturing him
sets up people as we talked about in the
second segment of our broadcast tonight
and then there are nights
when he is just a splendid score and
tonight is one of those nights the luke
of magic
is showing out in quarter number one
i'm talking about assists who could say
the heck with an assist
isaiah hartstein is at the scores table
ready to come into the game
for the clippers now luke bernard no
foul was called he had his hands all
over him still didn't keep him out of
the pain as lucas scores on the floater
inside
they stay close despite the fact that
they've had a front row seat for the
luca show
oh my
oh hi
three-pointer number six
they're calling me when a guy starts
launching it from the logo
a lot of people are watching trust and
believe in the post-game interview with
us he was mad that he missed the ninth
one and it is luca hey
in a world of hurt again
oh look at that smile
is 29 by dirk nowitzki and 28 is the
number right now for luca with a minute
21 to go what will the clippers do
they're chasing it with zubots give back
to him there it is and there it is seven
threes made in the first quarter he'll
offer the drive to the basket and flips
it in 30 points now powell did a good
job closing out that time under control
against the lock
in the shot clock hello
all those nights for luca man everything
is hard yeah absolute rim and that sets
up everything else in this game andy i
think he plays bigger that's like a walk
in the park left right there he was
freeze in the first half now it's going
to the cup he's dancing
the scouting report on reggie
close out
two more for luca timeout ty lue
dejectedly
frustratingly
he calls time out bigger zubat this time
a smaller powell
gets taken advantage of
here's luca who absolutely set the place
on fire with his three-point shooting in
the first quarter
he missed that attempt
here's green here's luca and there's 41
points
for the phenom
you take a look at bronson getting in
the lane nice little cut by green
luca gets him an easy one sometimes a
change of scenery just puts a guy right
back at where he needs to be and and you
got to think with a guy like luca
creating the havoc that he does there's
gonna be a lot of shots more having four
havoc by the way
[Applause]
and clawing and grabbing the shake
looser
but it's just a smooth move to the cup
for 49
[Music]
very short list
[Applause]
and now to make this a seven point lead
with 40 seconds left
clippers for the first time this season
dallas is 10 games over 500 at 33 and 23
and the men of the hour the hit maker
the record breaker luka doncic with 51
points tonight the highest scoring game
of his career
we're gonna witness it i mean it was
just a
incredible performance